another idea that you've uh that you've
got that i think is fascinating uh is
this whole idea of like buying the dip
may be sub-optimal and i think it really
gets at this whole
question of like if i have a pot of
money uh should i just put it all into
the market today or should i try to
dollar cost average over time uh i know
you've done some work on this like how
do you maybe just like frame the
question that you're trying to actually
answer and then what is the answer
yeah so let's use a more like ridiculous
thought experiment right let's say you
had a hundred million dollars and you
have to like preserve that purchasing
power over the next hundred years you
have two options you either get it all
invested right now today
or you put in one million dollars a year
for the next 100 years so i know you
already know the answer to this right
like why would you wait where would you
put in a millionaire for the next
hundred years inflation's gonna eat you
alive right like i'm i'm very i don't
like holding cash so as a result like
it's obvious that you should put it in
immediately well take that general idea
and generalize it down right if you
wouldn't wait a hundred years you
shouldn't wait 100 months you shouldn't
wait 100 days right like that because
generally you know prices go up and to
the right for asset classes over time
that's not true of every market all the
time but for most markets most of the
time that's what happens for at least
income producing assets so because of
that you're not going to want to wait
and i've tested this in so many things
like putting the money in now versus
waiting and putting in over time and
this is true i've done this with gold
i've done this with bitcoin i've done
this with you know international stocks
i've done those the u.s stocks etc and
all of them it's better to like on
average like 70 to 80 of the time it's
better to start and invest now instead
of waiting for dips and things like that
because usually when you wait for these
types of dips the dips will happen but
by the time that dip comes down that's
at a higher price than you could have
bought originally i think one of the
best examples of this is i actually
started talking about this in early 2017
and people were like oh the market's too
overvalued i'm not going to buy and
since then like the market's doubled but
even if you had bought like on the bot
at the bottom in march 23 2020 you still
would have bought it prices like seven
percent higher than if you had just
bought in like early 2017 which is kind
of shocking like even if you could
perfectly time the market and get the
best dip possible like three years after
um you know when i first started talking
about this you still would have bought
at higher prices which is kind of crazy
to think but that's kind of how dips
happen right the big dips or dips are
rare and big dips are incredibly rare
yeah and so this one goes to this whole
idea of like just like time in the
market is more important than timing the
market which is you know a really cute
saying but but there is a ton of truth
to this and i think that that data kind
of backs it up